so Steve enamel is a rare example of an
actor who is as cool as the superhero he
portrays on TV he's gotten into this
awesome shape so he's been able to do
these iconic workout scenes involving
things like the Salmon Ladder upside
down sit-ups rope climbing so this led a
lot of viewers to ask me if I could do
video on this channel looking at how
Steve enamel trains and how Aero trains
and the good news is that as I
researched it it turns out there's a lot
to talk about here and I thought it'd be
also cool to look at how arrow himself
might train to develop his kind of
accuracy in his master Archer skills so
without further ado let's get into it so
like I said arrow is kind of synonymous
with those awesome bodyweight moves like
the Salmon Ladder where you're climbing
a ladder using a rung that kind of slots
into place and you're just exploding up
with your body strength looks awesome
and it's actually quite a functional
display of strength so in order to get
that kind of strength and explosiveness
Steve enamel used mostly bodyweight
training calisthenics he did a range of
color variations planking balance
exercises press ups etc and he told
Men's Fitness in an interview that he
much more respect someone who can do
thirty pull-ups versus someone who can
benchpress 300 pounds because he thinks
there's just a lot more real world use
whereas the bench press is kind of more
for show you know the most impressive
things that I can do on the show or when
I can manipulate my own body weight and
that that really is the true test of
strength I'm much more impressed if
someone can do thirty pull-ups then
bench three hundred pounds because one
has has an actual application in the
real world theoretically the other is
just for show and the great thing about
this is that when you're doing
bodyweight exercises like that you're
involving your core a lot you have to
stabilize yourself balance and press ups
like I've said are a great way to
flatten your stomach in your abs as I
pull ups and those upside down twisting
pull-ups or training your Bleek's and
the lower abs it's a great way to really
develop that kind of toned physique that
Stephens got in the show and he also
combined this with a diet where he
avoided gluten processed sugars and
dairy not because he thought there was
anything evil about dairy or gluten but
just because that was a good way of him
structuring his diet so that he could
avoid eating those things that he didn't
want
in order to keep his calories low in
order to stabilize his blood sugar so if
you combine these calisthenics with a
low sugar diet and presumably a
relatively low calorie diet running
which he also said he did and lots of
martial arts training and parkour we
know he does then you have a recipe for
lean and that explains why he looks the
way he does if you want to train to do
that kind of move though you're gonna
need to use progressions you can't just
go straight up to a Salmon Ladder and
start ascending and likewise I wouldn't
recommend that you hang upside down from
your legs until you're pretty confident
in your strength and your ability to
climb back down so progressions in
bodyweight training me basically you're
training with an easier bodyweight
exercise to start with and you're
building up something more difficult so
that might mean that you're doing
assisted pull-ups to begin with it might
mean that you then do regular pull-ups
might mean that you try and do as many
as you can then you can start being
explosive doing claping pull-ups and
then you're ready to try the Salmon
Ladder and that's true of all kinds of
exercises if you want to be able to do
the planche then meeting first train
with the plank and then you can use the
Maltese push-up where you're changing
the angle of your hand slightly so you
we're basically building up to what you
need to do sounds obvious but a lot of
people think the calisthenics just means
doing endless push-ups and endless
sit-ups it's also important if you're
going to do calisthenics is your main
form of exercise and you make it
challenging enough and a great way to do
that is with mechanical drop sets so
here you reverse the order and you start
with the harder exercise and then when
you can do no more you drop down to the
lower one so you might do as many
clapping press ups as you camp then you
do regular press ups and you do press
ups on your knees it's great to really
feel the burn and you can get a full
workout with calisthenics that way so
another reason that Stephen amell's says
he trained this way is because it's more
similar to how Oliver Queen might
trained himself so if you know the story
Oliver Queen gets trended Long Island
has to fend for himself five years and
that's how it develops the speed and the
skill and the strength that allows them
to become arrow and if you really were
training on an island you wouldn't be
doing curls and things you'd be doing
pull-ups from tree branches you'd be
lifting heavy logs and rocks and you'd
be running up and down hills and that's
very similar to something called mob nap
which is a exercise movement that
involves training in the world just like
this
swimming through freezing cold rivers
doing pull-ups from trees and this is an
incredibly functional way to train
because when you do a pull-up from a
tree no two pull ups are ever the same
because the tree branch is always gonna
be different it's gonna be thicker at
one point and thinner at another it's
gonna be higher at one point and lower
another and you might have to have a
reach strained angle and every push-up
every pull up you do is different and
that means you're training completely
different supportive muscles the core is
highly involved and your body just has
to adapt and that's incredibly
functional if you think about it the way
we train is almost like domesticated
it's like a comfortable gym everything
is flat and straight we're using lots of
straight lines and that's not really how
we would move in the wild so if you want
to be truly functional then you need to
train outdoors or you just need to
inject a little bit of the element of
the unknown I talked about this in my
video I uploaded recently on functional
training versus isolation training and
being stranded on an island will also
make you much more Hardy like I say
we're domesticated we love our warm
showers and if it's a little bit cold
outside then we chicken out and go back
home but obviously if you lived in the
wild you'll be forced to just deal with
the cold and man up and you'd be forced
to keep on exerting yourself even when
you're exhausted if you haven't found
food you need to keep on going so
swimming from cold Lakes and training
outdoors it can do get the opportunity
is a great way to not only build really
functional strength but also mental grit
and this comes through in Oliver's
character a little bit in the show but
if you want to train like this you don't
have to abandon yourself in the
wilderness for five years it's a little
bit extreme so instead what you can do
is to just inject a little bit of
creativity in your workouts for instance
instead of just doing the pull-up tie
your towel around your pull-up bar and
do the pull-up from the towel
that'll make it a little bit more
different and inject an element of the
unknown into your training and Stephen
amell's said in the same interview that
he likes to keep his workouts unique
keep the body guessing likewise that
might mean sitting on a BOSU ball was to
do your regular exercises or might be
standing on one leg whilst you do your
regular exercises just anything that
makes the body the whole body work and
makes it more aware of your body in
space and we'll get to more of why
that's important in a second
another really awesome way to Train
similar skills is to do rock climbing
rock climbing trains of grip strength
your lap strength your explosiveness and
your stamina all at the same time and if
you've seen someone do a dyno which is
where they're holding onto juggling
launch themselves in the air and catch a
higher-up
grip on the wall and that's very similar
to the Salmon Ladder and it feels
incredibly dynamic and explosive
strength so if you want to be able to do
that then try rock climbing and
specifically bouldering bouldering means
shorter walls so you don't need a rope
and there's a crash mat underneath it's
still a challenge to get to the top and
you can make it harder for yourself by
not using your legs or by taking the
harder route and it's a great way to
workout a lot of gyms have them so if
you want to try it look up Boulder ring
in your area and you can also train this
way in the gym you just need to be a bit
more functional about the way you
approach it so Steve enamel does
sometimes do traditional resistance work
he does use weights but he's be more
likely to use something like a
kettlebell versus a dumbbell and
likewise he'll make it more difficult
and challenging in different ways for
instance standing on a BOSU ball or
sitting on one and just making it once
again more functional kettlebell
training anything like that it builds a
much more complete strength that you can
use when fighting or when running
through the woods or doing parkour
because you're using your body has one
functional unit rather than isolating
each individual part and we also know
that Steve enamel does parkour and he
didn't actually know parkour before he
started filming arrow he learned it for
the show which is just a testament to
how cool this guy is because if you
watch him doing the stunts in the show
they're pretty incredible parkour
obviously is a form of CPU running but
it's also throwing things that you have
to climb over walls of different heights
after hurdle things from home monkey
vault etc and all of this builds once
again a very dynamic and explosive
strength something to consider if you
want to be more Aero like and of course
it'd be very useful for running along
with rooftops so the really cool thing
about Steve enamel is that here he's
developed a training program that
reflects the way that the character
would have trained if he were real so
that means that he's able to get not
only the look of the character and
really embody him but also the
performance to an extent and also to get
into the mindset of a character and
that's something that hugh jackman said
he did when he was training to be
wolverine he'd stand in the shower under
freezing cold water and just yelled to
get into that feral wild mindset and
it's really important to have a training
philosophy because when you have a
philosophy
about the way you train you're not just
trading because you think you're
supposed to or because you want to look
hot or because everyone tells you to
then it gives you more motivation and it
allows you to prioritize the things that
really matter to you Roxy Steve enamel
is an actor and arrow is a superhero and
you can't do everything that the
character does and he says himself there
are some things he'd change about his
training if he was really arrow for
instance he says he wouldn't do such
explosive training all the time for the
lats because in archery you need lots of
strength but also perseverance and
stamina to pull the the boat back and
then let it go so he says he would train
maybe with a slower cadence using a
cable or a lat pulldown and he would do
it while sitting on a focusing ball once
again to really train the abs and the
core but of course the real skill of
arrow is to aim perfectly every time he
fires although you don't see that as
much in the show as maybe you could
that's definitely the main power of
arrow he's a master Archer like Hawkeye
or Legolas in order to get better at
aiming with a bow and arrow of course
the simple way to do it is to practice
archery go to a class this is said
specific adaptations to impose demands
you wanna get better at something you
practice that thing and your body and
your brain will adapt but of course not
all of us have the time or the ability
to go to an archery class you might not
have one near you so of course anything
that will train your hand-eye
coordination and your aim you can
practice that and you'll get better so
that could mean throwing a tennis ball
against the wall it could be engaging in
a different sport it could mean that
you're juggling juggling is one of the
best things you can do and actually
really interestingly virtual reality
could be a fantastic way to train your
hand-eye coordination and your aim so
I've talked in the past about how a
virtual reality can be useful for
training your brain but it might also be
useful for training physical skills in
one study it was found that children who
had practiced using light gun games you
know like house the dead shooting the
gun at the screen were better at aiming
in real life than kids who hadn't it
might seem obvious but it basically
means that's a transferable skill that
can come across and virtual reality
opposite can take it to the next level
by fully immersing you in that world
I've been playing a lot of a game called
eleven and eleven is basically a table
tennis simulator and it's super
realistic and a lot of people say it's
so realistic that it actually proved
their real-world table tennis skills so
in theory you can have a real war room
in your room by
using virtual reality and as more
applications come along we'll see
hopefully more of this kind of thing but
it's incredible what potential virtual
reality has for training all kinds of
skills there's something I've been
looking at more in a future video and
also important is to be more mindful as
you're practicing your aim so in one
study basketball players use the
technique called the quiet eye and here
they would focus on the rim of the
basketball hoop for just a fraction of a
second before they through that it
improves their accuracy by 22 percent
basically the more you focus on
something the more importance you give
it to your brain and this is important
for stimulating brain plasticity so if
you are going around practicing catching
and throwing or playing a computer game
be more mindful of that fact and it will
improve your skill at a faster rate and
you can also introduce ways to train
your aim throughout the day so that
might mean throwing teabags into a mug
or just throwing your clothes and
catching them before you put them in the
wash basket and again just be more
conscious as you're doing it and make it
into a little training exercise and it's
not just important to be more aware of
the object you're aiming at and the
object that you're firing or throwing
but also your own body and space and
this is called proprioception and always
played bowling although how important is
to use the correct technique if their
wrist is slightly twisted and that shot
isn't going to score a strike so you
need to not only focus on the objects
but also on yourself and you need to
develop your prior section in other ways
and this is something actually the kind
of training that Stephan ml does would
help because if you're training
explosively and more dynamically and if
you're involving balancing then you are
more conscious of your body in space as
you're training
and particularly good for this a
contralateral movements which involve
using your limbs out of sync so
spider-man crawlers are a perfect
example and that's said to improve your
proprioceptive and your awareness of
your body in space so now we're more
aware we've got better aim but it's also
important to improve our vision you need
to be able to track the object that
you're aiming at with your eyes and you
need to be able to focus on it because
obviously it's not very good to be great
at firing things and perfect day but not
does see what you're shooting at and if
your arrow and you're fighting bad guys
then they're gonna be moving around they
don't just stand still so tracking
fingers of your eyes is actually a skill
you can develop and you can find
exercises on computers to let you do
this and it just involves following
things as they move around the screen
with the rice and you can also do this
in real life by watching things
like a fly and if you try and just
follow a fly's movements with your eyes
it's very difficult this is a great
exercise for improving that particular
skill and another one is the near fire
drill
this basically means putting an object
about 18 inches away from you and then
another one about 10 foot away from you
and the idea is that you focus on the
one knee and then you focus on the one
further away and you switch between them
and this of course trades your ability
to switch your focus quickly in a future
video I'm gonna be looking at peripheral
vision and how that can help you to
develop more of a flow state and more
awareness and of course this is
something that era would have really
needed on the island because he was
constantly being hunted by prey had to
be aware of everything all around him at
all times and interested in playing
regular computer games can also improve
your visual acuity and your ability to
make snap decisions under stress these
are shooting games but they don't have
to be virtual reality or even use a
light gun so if you play a lot of cod or
halo then according to research
you're better at making out enemies on
the horizon and you're better at quickly
deciding which one to prioritize when
you're aiming when you really think
about it it's kind of incredible that we
can ever successfully hit a target you
have to do amazing maths in a fraction
of a second you have to calculate the
speed and the distance of the object
that you're aiming at and its trajectory
you have to think about the trajectory
of the object you go throw make sure it
hits it when it lands there never think
about the weight of the object you need
to think about the wind the angle and
all of this in a fraction of a second we
actually use a part of our brain to
calculate all this that we don't
normally have access to for performing
regular maths and there is a guy who can
use that part of the brain and he can do
it in such a way that you perform sums
quicker than a calculator and of course
I'll be talking about that in future
videos and on the website so there's a
bunch of ways you can train a little bit
more like aeronaut I need to develop the
body of arrow but also is explosive
strength and speed and potentially his
aiming skills as well and the last thing
to consider is how you're gonna fit all
this into your regular training program
because most of us don't have time on
top of everything else we do to do
near-far drills or to track objects with
the rise or to train our grip or our
lats and my answer to that is I've
talked about in the Batman training
video to have a skills workout this is
one day out of your regular workout that
it focuses on all their cool skills that
you don't have time for in the regular
splits that means things like
flexibility or
rip strength orale so that's when you
can do those kinds of things like the
near-far drill and develop really cool
skills that will give you the edge over
everyone else in the gym so this make
sense to me because it fits my training
philosophy which is GPD which stands for
general preparedness training basically
being ready for anything and if that's
the kind of training that appeals to you
then follow some of this advice and you
should be right on target
that was cringe
so thanks ton for watching guys hope you
found this video useful and interesting
if you did then please like please share
I put a ton of effort into this video
this is the first day where I've spent a
whole day just working on the bio neon
I'm gonna be doing this every week so
this was a big video just to get us
started but I'm gonna be doing lots of
small ones a few more big ones mixing it
up is gonna be loads more content on the
website so please subscribe it really
helps me out and doing everything I can
to try and make this channel a success
and it means the world to me that you
guys watch this video and comment it's
great so yeah thanks again for watching
stay tuned for lots more cool stuff on
the way and I'll see you next time bye
for now